- Well, you were so young
when your father passed.
What memories do you have of him?
- Yeah, you know, I tell people,
unfortunately, I only have one.
But it's a special one,
because it's the only one
that I shared with him,
but none of the other siblings shared.
And that was a little
game that we would play
when he would come home.
And I would run up into
his arms, and he said,
"We're gonna play the kissing game today."
And essentially what that
was is, each one of us
had a spot on his face.
My brothers on either side of the cheek,
I was on the forehead, my
sister was off to the side
of the mouth, and my mom was, of course,
smack dead in the middle there.
And he would say, "Okay, where is-",
and he would just call everybody's name.
My nickname was Bunny,
like the bunny rabbit.
"Where is Bunny's kiss?"
I would hit him there,
and he actually would
call them sugar spots.
You know, in the black
community we called them,
"Gimme some sugar."
So, I gave him some sugar
on each one of those spots
as he called each person's name.
And that was our little
bonding experience,
because when I was born, he
started traveling even more.
And so, he wasn't home as
much, and I think he felt
that he needed to do something special
so that I would have
that connection with him,
because my father always had a sense
that he was not gonna live a long life.
And so, he wanted to make sure
that there were meaningful
moments with each one of us.
- Well, that's a
beautiful memory.
(audience clapping)